one week on there'll be some really
tough moments especially at work when
you're feeling a bit tired and you'd and
you're not that interesting that work
that you should be doing and Facebook's
the one thing that you can just do
without much brainpower my sleeping
habits are better my getting up habits
are better my work productivity is
better it's been a week although as I
thought you'd actually been two weeks
because it does feel longer and it's
very strange because as out with some
friends last night and they kept on
saying I would did you see such-and-such
on Facebook or that comment on Twitter
by Center and oh no you couldn't see
that could you which I found really
irritating you know I'm coping without
it it's just every now and then I think
oh I just post something or I look at
this and I can't the fear of missing out
for me is real because of missing things
on Facebook particularly groups I belong
to I'm also missing out terribly on
family photographs but granddaughter has
just moved up from me at five to year
six
it's a big year for her and there are
photographs of her at school which I
haven't seen I have deleted the apps
just because it removes any sort of
temptation you have you know I'm off the
bone quite a lot it's like I notice like
other people having the phone more it's
like they're you know I'll be on public
I'll look around and it's like oh you
know everyone's got one social media is
something that kind of weighed me down I
felt the constant need to bet on all the
time but actually I don't have a
constant need to be on it all the time
I have a need at all to be on it I've
come to this realization
oh I don't actually need it as much as I
thought I did and it's just where oh
okay